we're so happy to see you making a
comeback Joe Jonas because we have to
admit we really missed you ever since
you left the Disney Channel and put the
Jonas Brothers on hold we were convinced
that you are done with the limelight but
now we get to jam out to your music all
over again we loved watching you on the
Disney Channel
especially in Camp Rock so we were
stunned when we found out that you
auditioned for a role in Wizards of
Waverly Place but didn't make the cut
it's hard to believe that the Disney
Channel would say no to Joe Jonas but he
isn't the only big Disney star who
missed out on a golden opportunity keep
watching to find out which actor beep
Joe to his desired role Selena Gomez is
there anyone in the world who doesn't
know who's the lien of Gomez is yeah we
highly doubt it the pop singer
extraordinaire got her big break on the
Disney Channel and she's moved on to
land some seriously awesome movie roles
but before becoming a Hollywood
sensation Selena had to turn a few
disney channel roles down
selena was approached to play a certain
role in highschool musical as well as
Mitchie in camp rock but Selena decided
to focus her attention elsewhere Miley
Cyrus but Selena wasn't the only one who
was being approached for big-time roles
out of nowhere after starring in
Disney's Hannah Montana from 2006 to
2011 Miley was about ready to pursue her
musical dreams for real so when she was
approached to be a judge on The X Factor
Miley didn't hesitate to turn it down
according to the star she just didn't
want to be some dream crusher who told
aspiring artists that they didn't have
what it takes to make it big Lindsay
Lohan this former Disney star also
missed out on a golden opportunity but
in the end it was her choice to part
with the role of Blair Waldorf
before Leighton Meester snags the Gossip
Girl lead Lindsay was slated to play the
queen bee of the Upper East Side so what
happened for Lindsay to ditch the gig
well she wasn't ready to commit to a TV
series as it turns out Gossip Girl was
originally supposed to be a movie and
not a TV show Zac Efron this former
Disney Channel star is one of the most
successful child actors of
all time but before becoming the
hilarious Hollywood star we all know and
love
he was typecast as a Disney Channel
triple threat so despite having already
accepted the role of Ren MacCormack in
Footloose Zac eventually chose to back
out of the deal
Zac wanted to step away from the musical
side of acting and take on more
challenging roles he didn't want
everyone to think that singing and
dancing was all that he was ashley
tisdale this Disney Channel Legend is
famous for playing Maddie Fitzpatrick on
The Suite Life of Zack and Cody and
Sharpay Evans from the High School
Musical franchise amongst many other
things she's driven and devoted which is
why she turned down the chance to
audition for her hit TV shows like
Pretty Little Liars in The Vampire
Diaries in the end
Ashley decided to focus on her show
Hellcats instead Bella Thorne you can't
talk about the Disney Channel without
talking about Bella Thorne she's just
that iconic I seem to remember somebody
accusing me of being a human being
Bella's gone on to have a very
successful acting career and she's not
done yet back in 2015
Bella was cast as Nina Paterson on
screen the TV series and appeared in a
total of three episodes but as it turns
out Bella had been offered the show's
leading role however she chose to pursue
Nina's character instead because in her
opinion it felt more iconic Vanessa
Hudgens we all know who Vanessa Hudgens
is she's a staple in the Disney
Channel's history but landing roles
outside of the Disney Channel universe
hasn't always been easy for Vanessa a
micro Disney Channel co-stars Vanessa
actually auditioned for a role in
Twilight New Moon but ended up losing
the part to another actress Vanessa was
being considered for the role of Leah
Clearwater but Julia Jones snagged it in
the end bridgit mendler bridget is known
for playing Juliet van Huston on Wizards
of Waverly Place from 2009 to 2012
but before snagging the lead role of
teddy duncan on good luck charlie
Bridget audition for another very
popular Disney Channel sitcom she
auditioned to play sunny Monroe in sunny
with a chance but ultimately lost the
part to Demi Lovato we're not bad about
it though because losing this role led
to her becoming the teddy duncan we all
deserved
sterling night if Bridget had landed the
role of sunny she would have co-starred
alongside sterling Knight on sunny with
a chance but we can't imagine anyone
else but Demi Lovato playing Chad Dylan
Cooper on screen love interest but
Bridget and Sterling do have something
in common they both auditioned for a
role they didn't get sterling auditioned
to play Troy Bolton in High School
Musical but lost the part - Zac Efron
and let's just say that sterling wasn't
too happy about this Joe Jonas what dude
Joe Jonas and Selena Gomez have in
common except for being famous Disney
child actors turned singers that is well
they almost played brother and sister on
on the hit Disney Channel series Wizards
of Waverly Place that's right Joe Jonas
auditioned for the role of Justin Russo
but lost the part to David Henry and
that's a wrap before you go tell us who
your favorite Disney Channel star is in
the comments section below hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to get
this video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll catch you next time on
the things
[Music]